reports are saying mr johnson has told
aides
that carrie simmons is out of control
and she is buying
gold wallpaper are they living
in bucknam palace or 10 down the street
because i don't really understand what's
going on here
it doesn't make sense to me but the
prime minister's office
are insisting that the money is coming
out of his own pocket
uh but reports are saying otherwise that
he either took
or borrows 58 000 pounds from a tory
donor
lord brownlow to the conservative party
huh i mean the prime minister gets 30
000 pounds
from the taxpayer to contribute towards
work
at number 11 downing street and number
10 downing street every year
but after going skint from his ex-wife
maria wheeler where is he getting the
extra money from
i don't know where it's coming from do
you know where it's coming from
to answer your questions and to find out
more
about what the british people are
thinking about this sleaze
reinmark passes on the streets of london
to get your thoughts and to see how much
you think
all of these outlandish furnishings
actually cost
over two we're thanks ryan mark i'm here
on the streets of london to find out
exactly
what the british people make of boris
johnson's ridiculous
spending so far an official
investigation has been launched into
whether the donation
that came from lord brownlow has broken
the law
and whether it is ethical i mean we have
some examples of exactly what boris
johnson has been spending his money on
for example 840 pounds for a roll of
wallpaper
and then we have 800 pounds and a baby
bear sofa
what even is a baby bear sofa 3 000
pounds
on a lily drum table i mean come on
even more money is being spent on
flooring that has been stripped
and polished the list keeps going on and
on and on and the spending keeps going
up and up and up resting currently at
200 000 pounds
what is this all about i'm here to find
out exactly what the british people
think
and we have pictures of boris johnson's
furnishings and i can't wait to find out
can i ask you one little question about
this so this is a gorgeous
table coffee table i want you to guess
how much this costs
1 000 pounds you kidding this is 3
000 pounds yes unbelievable
how much do you think this table is
worth this gorgeous coffee table
oh a coffee table
30 pounds 30 pounds is that how much you
would pay for this table
probably around 35 how much would you
pay 75. so what if i told you this table
here is 3
000 pounds what's your reaction not
worth it
and what about this here this wallpaper
would you make a bag
oh my god it's a monstrosity it's
ghastly isn't it
how much would you pay for a roll of
this i certainly wouldn't pay 800 and
is egregious
what do you think of this delightful
wallpaper this makes me feel a bit
uneasy
uneasy in what way it reminds me of my
dad's house
the table of the chairs the table this
gorgeous coffee table here
okay it's very round and soft looking
it holds plates it does hold plates
would you buy this for your house
i don't have a house
well both actually tell me i personally
pay about 650.
650 quid for this yeah and how much do
you think it's worth
probably more than that guess any idea
12.50 what would you how would you react
if i told you it's nearly ten thousand
pounds
ten thousand pounds for this and you
know who owns this sofa no
so is it mrs jones it's mr boris johnson
what are your thoughts on this wallpaper
yeah absolutely disgusting
disgusting yeah it looks vintage but not
something i'll put in my house so how
much would you pay for this sofa
i don't believe in the concept of fun
[Music]
i'll pay a couple hundred for that like
it looks like it's made out of bamboo
well this is three thousand pounds
what's your reaction my reaction is
i'm not currently obscene there were
people dying
and that is just not what needs to be
well there you have it i've asked the
people of britain what they make
of all of this junk and the conclusion
is
people in britain don't have any class
or taste where are their standards
nowhere to be seen well brilliant that
was a fascinating insight into what the
british people
really think about boris johnson's flat
renovations
just make sure you continue paying your
taxes so that carrie simmons
can get another batch of gold wallpaper
see you next